bonsoir nils first run merci à d'autres
avec nous en direct sur rt france est
vrai que la suède on en a beaucoup parlé
lors de la première vague il faisait
plutôt office d'exemple on voit que la
situation se dégrade
comment on se l'expliquent sur place
alors oui il est vrai que le nom de le
nombre de cas depuis la mi-octobre
augmentent de manière exponentielle
ce qui est très triste je suis pas un
expert en virologie je pense que c'est
très difficile à dire je pense que deux
hypothèses sont plausibles
d'abord c'est un virus qui est très
certainement saisonniers comme une
grippe donc les restrictions sont restés
les mêmes jusqu'à récemment
depuis mars mais malheureusement une
nouvelle vague est apparue en octobre
donc c'est un virus qui est probablement
très probablement saisonniers et de plus
si le virus a probablement muter ce qui
ce qui fait que d'errer infections sont
possibles aussi de nombreuses études qui
ont été publiés qui monte des cas de
réinfection sur sur les mêmes patients
donc je pense que ce virus probablement
reviendra à chaque hiver jusqu'à jusqu'à
ce qu'on trouve une situation durable
avec propos potentiellement un vaccin ou
autres mesures
vous vous êtes médecin effectivement on
nous parlait dans ce reportage de la
situation dans les hôpitaux à stockholm
99 % des lits de réanimation sont
occupés c'est bien ça ça présage de ce
qui peut se passer sur le reste du
territoire
alors c'est une diffusion c'est une
situation qui est très difficile à
stockholm et effectivement c'est comme
si la capitale la plus grande
concentration de personnes et les
services de réanimation sont surmenés
après si on regarde de haut niveau
national on a hier on avait deux cent
cinquante neuf personnes qui étaient en
réanimation simultanément alors qu'en
avril le pic était à 522 donc plus du
double de cas en réanimation
simultanément les capacités nationales
de son ne sont absolument pas atteinte
encore
mais la situation est très sérieuse il
ya un nombre de cas qui est beaucoup
plus élevé par jour toutefois c'est
parce qu'aussi pas ce conte est beaucoup
plus mais il ya quand même un gros taux
d'infection mais il ya moins de cas
hospitalisés et de 15 des animations que
pendant la première vague le
gouvernement pris des mesures on a
entendu la fermeture des lycées est ce
que vous en tant qu'homme médecin
s'avoue satisfait les mesures du
gouvernement sont plutôt bien
accueillies en suède
juste une petite précision je suis
externe ne pas pas encore aux médecins
mais écoutez je trouve que les mesures
sont bien et les gens les gens les
prennent très au sérieux c'est à dire
qu' il n'y a pas de de loi on va dire
comme en france où on risque de se
prendre des amendes etc
c'est plus des recommandations et les
gens les suivent à la lettre
moi pour être dans le milieu encore
étudiant ce pouvoir que que même les
étudiants qui pourrait être la catégorie
sociale qui serait amené à la respecter
l'eau - les restrictions le font
vraiment à fond donc c'est de mettre en
contact avec les personnes avec
lesquelles on vit et si l'on vit seul
choisir une ou deux personnes avec qui
on peut passer du temps mais pas plus il
fermait également les restaurants n'a
plus droit de servir de l'alcool après
22h 30 fermeture de salles de gym 200
commerciaux et que c'était donc il y à
des mesures de la suède prend prend
cette deuxième vague très au sérieux
alors c'est étonnant parce qu'il ya eu
un gros débat vous étiez un petit peu
l'exemple ou le contre exemple c'est
selon où il n'y avait pas finalement de
grandes restrictions lors de la première
vague le gouvernement avait choisi
justement d'être plutôt libérale de
l'essai voilà les personnes à leur
responsabilité de ne pas trop imposer
des restrictions
aujourd'hui c'est une volte-face on
pourrait dire ça je pense que la
stratégie de la suède dans cette
première partie de 2020 était de tout
d'abord de limiter la propagation du
virus pour ne pas surcharger les pour ne
pas surcharger les services de
l'animation et je pense que ça on a
réussi à le faire mais comme j'ai dit
précédemment ce virus est probablement
saisonnier il mute et je pense qu'on ne
pourra pas empêcher la propagation du
virus
complètement donc si on dresse un bilan
de la suède par rapport aux autres pays
d'europe je pense pas qu'on a un bilan
qui est moins bon que les pays qui ont
confiné et le confinement finalement
qu'est ce que ça fait c'est ça permet de
limiter les dégâts momentanément mais ça
ne fera pas disparaître le virus donc il
faudra espérer un vaccin ou d'autres
solutions alors justement le vaccin on y
vient puisque l'europe a fait une
commande groupée donc tous les pays
européens théorie seront à peu près
traités de la même manière vaccination
en début d'année prochaine commence à se
profile justement chez vous en suède
quelle est la stratégie de votre
gouvernement alors la stratégie l'aller
simple c'est de ces deux d'abord dans un
premier temps vacciner les personnels
hospitaliers et les groupes à risque
donc tous ceux qui sont au dessus de 65
ans ou qui ont des décos mobilité des
facteurs de comorbidité qui sont qui
sont au potentiel et dans un deuxième
temps commencer à vacciner la population
plus généralement mais ça on en parle on
ne parle pas de date fixe probablement
me printemps alors sauf que incarne un
des suédois n'a pas confiance en avec
sein développée en urgence à cause
notamment de la vaste campagne contre le
h100 h1n1 c'était en 2009
alors oui mais c est difficile de faire
confiance de faire confiance en
l'entreprise qui a développé un vaccin
si rapidement je pense que énormément
d'argent a été débloquée pour pour faire
de la recherche là dessus moi même je ne
saurais pas dire si je veux me faire
vacciner directement et j'attends de
voir quelques quelques études en plus
pour vérifier si le vaccin efficace
merci à nils personnes externes en
médecine l'hôpital de lund en suède
merci à vous